- So you love animals so much
you name all of them, right?
- Of course, yes.
- Okay, you have an animal game.
Do we have an animal game we're gonna do?
I'm gonna do an animal game.
- I would love to play an animal game--
- Okay, can we go through
some of your animal pictures?
- Yeah.
- And maybe the game is, you
tell us what their names are.
- Okay, yeah!
I hope I can remember.
(applause)
- Okay, let's see the first one.
Oh, oh my gosh!
[Kaley] That's the love
of my life, Norman.
He's been with me
- [Kelly] Norman!
- For 13 years--
- I love that you picked an old man name.
My dog's name is Henry.
- Oh he's full old man name, yeah.
- I love it!
- He's the love of my life.
- So cute, okay next picture.
- [Kaley] Oh, that's Simon, that's Simon!
(audience laughs)
By the way, as you can tell,
he only travels private.
(laughter and clapping)
- That is ridiculous.
- That's amazing!
- Look at him, he's like,
"Hey, can someone get me
a cocktail," look at him.
(audience laughs)
- Look at 'em, he's like poking up!
- I know!
- I love it, oh my gosh,
I love Simon.
Okay next.
Aw!
- [Kaley] Okay, that's my
new, he's a dwarf rescue goat,
and his name is Tarantula,
and don't question it
because look at him.
- He looks like a, yeah.
- Does he not look like a tarantula?
- He does look like a tarantula.
(audience laughs)
- Yup.
- And I swear, he knows his name.
It's so weird.
- I mean he looks like
a goat, but the coloring
is that of a tarantula, yes.
- Yeah.
Obsessed with that little guy.
- He's adorable.
- That's, oh!
That's Tank.
And there's Simon next to him.
- I think Tank wants to eat Simon!
- Yeah, look at Tank.
He's very proud of Simon.
Tank came with my husband, so I've, yeah--
- I love that his name is Tank!
- I mean, would you accept anything else?
- Oh my God, he's so great.
I love your--oh!
- And that's our super-model dog.
Uh, that's Blueberry.
She's our rescue pit bull
that we rescued this year.
- [Kelly] Does she have some,
oh what do they call, uh--
- She has contacts in her eyes.
(laughter)
- No but what?
No, I forget the name of the dog.
It looks--
- [Kaley] Oh, Weimaraner.
- Weimaraner! Weimaraner!
- She is not, but she's a--
- A mix?
- So she's like, yeah.
- Oh, she just looks like.
Okay I was like a Weimaraner.
- She's very special, we love her.
- [Kelly] Thank you Alex, Weimaraner.
(laughing)
Alright, well alright!
I love that you love your animals so much!
I love it!